a massive
explosion in the heart of the lebanese
capital
the blast sent shockwaves across beirut
shattering windows
destroying buildings
and injuring hundreds
the streets were filled with panic and
confusion
my car was down there it rolled over i
think my injuries are because of the
gloss
the glass cut me up my car was like this
i don't know what happened i was fishing
i heard there was a fire so i began to
head home
then i heard something explode and then
this happened i got injured this is all
i know
rescue work began quickly emergency
vehicles converged on the site of the
blast
putting out fires
[Music]
and getting the injured to safety
lebanon's internal security chief
confirmed the blast originated in the
port district
in a section housing highly explosive
materials
lebanon's prime minister hassan dieb
addressed the nation
promising that the victims would get
justice for what happened
it will not pass without accountability
those responsible for this catastrophe
will pay the price
this is a promise to the martyrs and
injured this is a national commitment
while the cause is still unknown some
are already blaming
the government lebanon is an accident
waiting to happen
in so many way so many places whether
it's
public services electricity all kinds of
government industries
are not regulated well we don't have
like inspectors that uh
so many buildings could collapse um so
you know again
all the problems that lebanon faces
because they don't really have a strong
government
that is able to ensure the safety of its
citizens um and that's been
why people have been protesting that's
why the currency has been falling
so you know there's so many possible
accidents in lebanon so
it's very hard to speculate ambulances
continue to arrive at the scene of the
explosion there have been dozens of
casualties
many victims are still trapped in the
rubble and rescue work looks set to
continue long
into the night the destruction of
central beirut appeared to come out of
nowhere
and as the shock of what happened
subsides the demands for answers will
continue
to grow louder al jazeera beirut